when you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change
Albert Einstein once observed that you
have the most fundamental and major
decision that you have to make in your
life is this do I live in a friendly or
a hostile universe which is it is it a
universe that is filled with hostility
and anger and people wanting to hate
each other and people wanting to kill
each other is that what you see because
when you see the world that way that's
exactly what you will create for
yourself in your life this is from great
scientific mind and the interesting
thing is that this is not just a a
clever play on words that when you
change the way you look at things the
things you look at change it's actually
a very scientific thing you're the one
with the struggles and with the
difficulties in expecting somebody else
to change or something outside of you to
get better in order for you to make your
life work at this level that I'm calling
intention is something you have to
really take a hard look at I used to say
that before I had children I had eight
theories about how to raise children and
now I have eight children and no
theories but one of the things I know
about children is that no one likes
being told what to do and this isn't
just children this is all of us don't
put boundaries on me don't tell me what
I can do and what I can't do don't tell
me how to be there don't tell me what to
wear what to think don't tell me how to
even how to do yoga don't tell me I
don't want to be told this is the sole
speaking always the soul is constantly
having a desire to expand and grow and
anything or anyone that comes into your
life that attempts to do that you will
find yourself fighting it and reaching
back you just watch - amazing clips from
Wayne Dyer take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]